[Musique]
après Marseille est le 93 les Yvelines
aussi ont leur compilation rap son nom
banlieue ouest mafia près de 50 artistes
originaires des quatre coins du
département ont répondu à l'appel de
chabodo depuis 2020 le trappiste a mené
ce projet qui se veut rassembler entre
les quartiers la tournée dans tous les
quartiers et surtout du 78 et il a senti
que il y avait un besoin d'être tous
réunis avec tout ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui dans les quartiers il
fallait envoyer un message positif et
aujourd'hui banlieus mafia c'est ce
message positif qu'ils envoient la
fouine Bosch ou encore le collectif 47
terres des noms connu du grand public
pose sur la compilation certains
artistes n'ont pas hésité même à sortir
de leur retraite pour se joindre au
projet c'est le cas de trésor membre du
duo l'escadrille dans les années 2000
tout bon rappeur il se doit de
représenter son département si tu le
fais pas et on t'appelle pas à le faire
c'est que tu as des manquements dans ta
technique et peut-être dans ton histoire
j'ai la chance d'avoir tout ça et donc
je le mets au bénéfice de mes petits
frères mettre en lumière les jeunes
talents des Yvelines c'est l'une des
autres ambitions de banlieue ouest mafia
cette suite c'est la famille étant donné
la force et on vient montrer ce qu'on
sait faire surtout aussi et il y en a
pas de moi
je vais apporter ma touche mon charisme
rester concentré et j'apporte la folie
c'est bon tu me parles de musique on va
rapper on va faire les trucs donc moi il
y a pas de complexe viens en rap il y a
pas de souci je fais ça depuis que j'ai
10 ans de toute façon je suis né pour ça
donc autant le vivre à 200 % la
compilation a même rassemblée au-delà
des Yvelines le DJ talk boxeur et roltay
mcloyd a collaboré sur 78 West Side un
morceau à la sauce rap old school
on va dire tout ce que West Coast donc
je fais pourquoi pas envoie le son on va
regarder ça en plus dessus à la fouine
voilà c'est les légendes 47 heures
Chabot magnifique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la compilation est disponible en
physique et sur toutes les plateformes